Is Peter White and I teach in the
mathematics department at Columbia
University,
or my title is senior lecturer.
Well,
the first thing I'd say is that when
people set talk about string theory,
they're actually talking about a very
complex set of ideas that um,
lots of people,
you know,
very large amount people have worked on
and done a lot of different things with
the,
um,
the probably what it's best known for
and what got people all excited about it
and the physics community is,
there's kind of like the conjecture that
instead of at the most fundamental level
you can understand matter in the
universe in,
in terms not of point particles.
Uh,
which is the way our best theories
currently you kind of understand things.
But in terms of kind of vibrating,
if you like vibrating kind of loops of
some elementary objects,
so you're at your elementary object
instead of being a point like thing is
something you should think of more as
being a one dimensional loop or a kind
of string string,
which is kind of moving around.
So it has a lot more,
um,
it can do a lot more complicated things
than a point.
This is kind of loop of elementary
matter,
whatever it is.
And so it,
it gives you a
very different kind of class of,
of theories and then the ones that,
um,
we've been so successful with before and
the,
the cafe.
So during the 60s that this idea was
initially developed and initially people
tried to do one thing with these class
of theories,
something which didn't work out that
well.
And then starting in the late seventies
and eighties,
people then,
um,
came up with the conjecture that maybe
you really could unify all of physics
and solve some of the open problems in
physics by replacing our standard
theories.
Maybe we call the standard model with
some kind of string theory.
And that's so,
so since this idea,
it became very popular in 1984 and so
it's been now 25 years.
People have been working very hard on
that.
And,
uh,
and,
and I think just the initial thing,
I've got people very excited,
at least I would claim,
you know,
really hasn't worked out and really
can't work out.
And that's kind of been,
I think a lot of the reason controversy
has been an argument over this issue of,
you know,
whether this,
um,
for a speculative idea about whether you
can use the strings to develop,
to get a unified theory about whether
that really has,
is that,
is that an idea that's failed or is
there still some hope for it?
I think that's really the,
uh,
what's the,
the controversial part of it?
Well,
the main thing to understand about the
current state of physics is that we have
in some sense kind of a victim of our
own success.
We have an incredibly successful theory
called the standard model.
And it,
um,
it,
it really explains everything that we
can observe about,
um,
in terms of a fairly small number of
elementary particles and some basic
forces between them.
And it's a,
it's a quite beautiful theory ended.
Um,
it really just kind of absurdly
successful every experiment,
anybody knows how to do that in
principle can be,
um,
did that,
this theory has something to say about
it.
It works.
It works out perfectly,
you know,
to,
to whatever experimental,
um,
in whenever you need,
how you can do an experiment to whatever
precision.
And it comes out exactly as predicted by
this model.
So we have kind of a semi unified
theory.
This,
we have this quite nice,
beautiful structure,
which explains everything we can see.
But it still,
it still leaves open.
So several questions and um,
some of the questions are just to kind
of why,
you know,
we have all these different particles,
they all have different masses.
Why do they all have different masses?
We don't understand why the electron has
a certain mass quirks of other masses.
So,
so they're just kind of things which the
theory just doesn't address.
It just doesn't answer these questions.
And they're questions that,
which has physicists we think there
should be answers to.
But then there's also one kind of
remaining forest,
which isn't part of the standard model,
which is the four,
which is the gravitational force.
And the,
um,
the gravitational force is much,
much weaker than these other forces.
And it's,
it,
it has a somewhat different nature.
So it,
the problem with it is that we don't,
um,
w w the,
the,
these other forces that we have
something which is a quantum theory.
It really,
it's,
it's quantum mechanics.
It really works down to the microscopic
level.
And in terms of this very fundamental
idea about,
about reality called quantum mechanics,
the theory of gravity that we still use
is Einstein's theory of general
relativity.
And it's what we call a classical
theory.
It's not a quantum mechanical theory.
And the,
um,
you can make an estimate.
The problem is that you can make an
estimate within this theory of how big
quantum mechanical effects would be.
And that estimate tells you that they're
just so absurdly small.
You can never hope to see them.
So there's kind of a problem with
principal.
We had this theory,
which is not a proper quantum mechanical
theory.
And we know that there's things which it
can't quite properly explained,
but there,
there's,
they're far too small for us to study
them and to,
to,
to try to see them.
So we would anyways.
So it's,
we're not completely happy with this
setup.
We have a,
a force which doesn't quite fit with the
others and uh,
which for logical reasons that we would
like to unify it with these others and
think and understand it as a quantum
mechanical theory and,
uh,
we've never quite been successful and
able to do that.
And,
and this is what strict string theory
was.
It was kind of a promise of a way of how
to do that.
And uh,
anyway,
that's kind of that,
that's why people got so excited.
Yeah.
It's Kinda,
it's kind of a famous phrase among
physicists.
It goes back to a,
and there's a well known theorist called
Wolfgang Pauli and the in the 50s
stories that towards the end of his
life,
someone,
I guess he goes,
he was well known for being a very kind
of hyper critical of,
of,
of things that were going on.
And we'll get up the middle of a seminar
and started saying,
you know,
it's wrong.
It's completely wrong.
And late in his life,
someone asked him about some work that
was some of some,
some speculative idea of someone and
heavily he shook his head and said,
well,
that one's not even wrong.
And,
and so the,
uh,
it,
it's,
it's a well known phrase among
physicists and it kind of carries I
think two,
two meanings.
I mean,
w w one one of them is just kind of a
more somewhat of a term of abuse.
Well,
that's so bad.
It's not even wrong,
but,
but there's a more interesting,
and there's also more kind of technical
meaning that
a very often used,
you have respect,
you have expected of idea.
And if it's,
if it's not a very good idea or it turns
out you actually can't even,
you end up not being able to do very
much with it,
you end up not being able to,
um,
to predict anything with it or to,
to,
or it's just not useful.
So there's also a notion of not being
not even wrong in the sense that it's
not an idea which can be fully developed
or it can turn into something which is
powerful enough to actually predict
something and be wrong.
So this one problem is string theory is
that it's kind of a I theory,
which they could explain what the
problems are,
but the problems are such that you can
ever even pin it down and say this is
exactly what it predicts and let's go
out and test it.
So it's not even capable of being wrong,
being wrong or being falsified are being
shown to be wrong.
So that's the more relevant meaning
here.
Really.
I said,
I mean it's string theory is actually a
very complicated stories.
So they're,
they're,
you know,
if you start out with this hypothesis
that maybe you're are,
our fundamental objects are not points,
but are these strings,
there's a lot of different things you
can try and do that you can,
you,
you have a whole different class of
theories you can play with.
And so I think a lot of,
if you look at what most people who are
still doing string theory doing,
they're actually not directly trying to,
um,
to develop as unified theory anymore.
They're off kind of doing other things
with string theory there that people
these days are trying to apply it to um,
to problems and nuclear physics.
They're applying it to problems and,
um,
in solid state physics,
understanding superconductors.
So they're,
the people who still are interested in
it,
you know,
are,
are often kind of,
even if they will,
they may or may not explicitly admit
that they've kind of given up on the
unified theory idea,
but they're,
they're often doing other things.
So there's a,
there's a very active,
um,
pursuit of string theory in,
you know,
with other applications that don't have
any to do with unification.
It's also turned out to be very
interesting.
And in mathematics,
there's a very,
one of the things that I'm most
interested in is the intersection
between mathematics and physics and um,
the way the two fields kind of affect
each other and ideas from physics lead
to very interesting things in
mathematics,
ideas and mathematics get used and they
give us new physics.
And string theory has been very,
very fruitful in terms of raising
questions,
which I'm happy to have led to very
interesting mathematics.
So there's a very active field of
research given between math and physics
in string theory,
but,
but it,
but it just doesn't seem to be relevant
to this question of unification.
Yeah,
I certainly shouldn't.
My critical criticism of string theory
is not that,
well,
you know,
if you guys would just realize that you
should be doing such and such,
that would,
that would solve a lot of problems.
I don't actually,
yeah,
I don't think that I have some my own
ideas,
which I'm very excited by,
which at which I'm pursuing,
which are also new ideas about how to
use mathematics to do things in physics,
which don't have anything to do with
string theory.
And,
and,
which kind of at least lead me to see
you there.
You know,
there's a lot of areas,
a lot of things we don't understand
which are closer to are the standard
model which we,
which we do know works.
There's a lot of kind of mathematical
mathematical structure behind the,
um,
the standard model,
which is still kind of mysterious and
which is not well understood.
And I think pursuing that is more likely
to get us somewhere then the districts
or unification idea,
just because you're starting from
something which,
you know,
a theory which you know is right.
And trying to further develop your
understanding of that theory is maybe a
more fruitful thing to do.
Then I'm trying to,
you know,
just kinda throw out,
throw the,
throw all that out and start a fresh
with something more speculative.
The,
um,
I guess it gets one thing to talk about
is,
is the,
uh,
this,
what's happening in Geneva even that,
this month,
that,
and so the,
uh,
a lot of the,
a lot of the problem with the field,
as I've said,
is this business of being a victim of
our own success,
not having any experimental results of
disagree with the theory,
which makes it very,
very hard to figure out how to,
how do you improve a theory if you've
got no kind of clues as to what,
you know,
what,
what might possibly be wrong that it
needs to be,
needs to be changed.
And so there's a,
this accelerator called the LHC okay.
At cern in Geneva.
And it's been in development for quite a
few years now.
And it's been a long process getting it
working.
But just over the past month,
they've finally got it to inject beams
into this accelerator and start
colliding these beams and start doing
some new physics.
And over the next year,
they'll start raising the energy of this
accelerator to the point where we'll,
um,
we'll,
we'll be in in a new energy regime
where,
which allows us to,
uh,
to,
to get experimental data about what's
happening at higher energy,
which also coat,
which corresponds to what's happening at
shorter and shorter distances to um,
to see what's happening in shortage.
Shorter distances.
In some sense you need to use shorter
and shorter wavelength or higher and
higher energy probes.
And this,
uh,
this new accelerator,
you know,
pr finally promises some data in this
new energy range beyond what we've been
able to see so far.
And there,
there are reasons to believe that this
new energy range is one where,
um,
that we can actually start to get
answers to some of these questions
about,
especially about mass,
about why,
why did different particles have
different masses?
Um,
so,
so the state of the standard model is
that it's as quite beautiful theory,
but you,
um,
to make the whole thing work,
you need a,
you need,
you need to make sure that a certain
kind of physical phenomenon.
It has to happen basically in one way of
saying it is that the theory has certain
symmetry is,
um,
and,
and the,
the lowest tenant,
the lowest energy theory,
the lowest energy state,
the vacuum of the theory has to have
nontrivial properties under one of the
cemeteries.
It can't normally you say vacuum state.
It's just kind of completely and
interesting.
And if you rotate it around,
move it around the vacuum,
nature can't,
nothing can happen.
It's just a vacuum state.
But,
um,
but the vacuum actually has to have
interesting properties under these kinds
of mathematical symmetry transformations
and the so,
so,
so we know that that has to be true in
order to make the theory work.
And there,
there are many ways you can imagine,
um,
making that happen.
And,
and one way is called the higgs,
the higgs mechanism.
And so the higgs mechanism involves a
postulating the existence of some,
some new fields and new kind of matter,
which is this,
this higgs part,
this,
this higgs field.
And,
um,
and,
and then giving this,
that he did the dynamics for the making
the properties of the higgs field such
that the,
that,
in the vacuum state,
the higgs field,
we'll have this done trivial property.
So you can do that in some sentence.
The higgs field is kind of the simplest
way of getting what you want,
but when you do it,
you also,
um,
you,
you end up losing the ability to predict
all sorts of things.
Cause then if some,
then there's the question of why,
why did,
why does the party,
we'll have a certain mass just becomes,
well,
because that's how strong,
it's how strongly it interacts with the
higgs field.
So you,
it's a simplest way of making something
happen.
You know,
it has to happen,
but it,
it,
it's a way which has a lot of things.
You don't really like it,
it's not a very satisfactory way of
doing it because it kind of of
necessity.
Then it leaves open a whole range of
questions and questions,
what you would hope to have answers to,
but you just from,
you just can't answer it that way.
So one thing which we hope to learn from
the LHC is,
is this higgs mechanism or does this
higgs field really there?
Um,
in,
in which case that,
that'll,
that'll be actually somewhat of a
disappointment because it'll mean that,
okay,
this theory kind of continues to work
and we don't,
we,
we still don't know how to answer some
of these questions or I think that the
much more exciting possibility is going
to be that there's some,
some,
something else causing this phenomenon
of the,
of the vacuum behaving this way.
And,
uh,
and,
and there's something else would be a,
you know,
give us,
um,
what would be,
it would be something which would be
more interesting and we'll,
and we'll allow answers to these
questions.
So instead,
so this whole,
this,
this name of the Higgs field and finding
the higgs particle,
that's kind of a,
it's an over simplified way of saying
what,
what we're really hoping,
which is we're really hoping to
understand what is causing the vacuum to
behave this way.
And,
uh,
and,
and we have good reason there.
There's,
there's kind of a number in the theory
which kind of says how big this
phenomenon going on in the vacuum is.
And,
um,
and what the size of it is.
And the size is exactly the size that
this,
uh,
this accelerator should finally be able
to probe.
So there's,
there,
there it's not,
um,
there's a very good reason to believe
that this is the right machine to kind
of start answering some of these
questions.
The real problem is that the,
the ways that we knew that there are
various ways,
a lot of people have studied a lot of
other alternatives to the Higgs field,
which I'm,
the problem is that they're all fairly
complicated and none of them,
they all have as bad or even worst
problem is in that the higgs field,
they've all,
so none of them are convincing.
We don't have the convincing alternative
to it.
And,
and I don't either.
I guess,
I mean the one about all I can say about
that is that the,
there I,
I'm very interested in,
in,
in some of the kind of mathematical
parts of the theory that we don't
understand and some of the kind of deep
mathematical structure that we don't
understand in our,
in these theories.
And part of what we don't understand it
and in these theories actually is,
you know,
is related to this problem of,
of the vacuum of this behavior,
of the vacuum.
So,
I mean in my ideal world it would turn
out that there's,
there's,
there's something there,
there's something still to be learned
about the mathematical structure of
these theories,
which would in the end,
you know,
explain this,
this higgs,
this higgs phenomenon,
this is problem with the vacuum.
But,
but I mean I,
I wish I knew how to do that,
but I certainly don't have a UN has a
very big reasons to believe are there.
That's an interesting thing to look at.
But,
but I,
I certainly don't have an answer to it.
And I think I get,
if I had to assign probabilities,
who had what,
I would a guess is that the,
I'd say there's about a 50% chance the
lhc will actually see an actual higgs
particle and there will be a,
there is some kind of higgs field and
that this is going to be kind of
depressing for us because it means,
well,
whenever there is this field there,
it's,
it's working like this and the answer
these questions,
we would like answers to our,
you'd have to go even higher energies or
a smaller distances to understand them.
And,
or there's,
there's,
I think there's a 50% probability we'll
find that we won't see a higgs particle,
or at least not a higgs particle,
the kind,
um,
that,
that you see in the simplest model and,
and that,
and that will actually give us clues as
to what's really going on.
And that will be much more exciting.
So,
but I don't know which is going to
happen.
You never know.
I mean there's no reason that you,
um,
the general problem that with particle
physics is that the,
these questions we're asking are at,
you know,
they're having such high energy scales
are such short distances that it's um,
it's very hard to see how to do anything
very practical with this.
I mean,
anything like these partners we're
talking about,
you know,
I have often have have lifetimes which
are,
you know,
10 to the minus 20 seconds or,
I mean they're,
they're,
they're just,
if you produce a higgs particle,
it's going to be so short lived it,
it's incredibly difficult to even see
any evidence of the thing.
It's not something you'd be able to go
out and use these higgs particles to
carry around and do something with it.
On the other hand,
I mean,
you,
you don't really know what you're going
to find it.
If you do find,
especially if you find something,
I guess I,
I could say it this way,
if you do just find this higgs particle
and just this higgs field,
it's very hard to debate to do anything
really practical with that.
If you,
if you find something completely new
understanding of this theory,
then who,
who knows?
I mean you can conject clay come up with
all sorts of models.
You can come up with models in which
there's kind of new heavy,
long lived particles which you could
then imagine doing things with.
But um,
I think it is probably a pretty good bet
that within the near future,
this is not really a big way of
practical.
This is really a matter of I'm just
trying to understand the world better
and not,
not,
not as many as,
not in a way,
but not in a way that's particularly
going to be useful for her for doing
anything too practical.
It's going to affect people anytime
soon.
I mean some of that is because people,
one of the alternatives to this is this
higgs mechanism is it,
and people started studying.
It sets out some models in which,
well,
to go back a little bit,
I mean one thing about string theory and
string theory,
to make string theory work,
you have to have extra dimensions.
You have to have more than a three space
and one time dimensions and that,
then that's kind of an in some sense,
the main problem with it with string
theory that you have to it,
you have to have at least five extra
dimensions.
I start,
sorry,
six extra dimensions.
And,
um,
the,
the predictions of the theory and being
able to use it for anything depending on
what's happening,
at least six extra dimensions.
And that's no one has ever,
initially,
the hope was that there was a fairly
small number of consistent ways of
dealing with these extra dimensions and
that would,
uh,
you know,
make this a predictive theory,
but it has turned out they're just too
much.
You can do and you can kind of get
anything you want by having these extra
dimensions to different things.
And so one,
one thing as part of this,
one thing that people studied was models
in which these extra dimensions are
actually of the executive,
the right size that the Lhd,
you should start seeing evidence of
these extra dimensions and then
producing black holes because it,
because of these extra dimensions and
that say,
um,
there's just never really been a reason
to believe that these extra dimensions
would,
we'd see no evidence of them at our best
accelerators now.
And we'd go up by a factor of seven and
energy and all of a sudden all these
extra benches would appear.
There's just,
there's,
there's absolutely no reason for that to
be,
to happen.
It's you,
you can make specked it a model in which
it happens,
but first of all,
then anyways,
so there's,
there's really kind of no Ma no good
motivation for these models and for them
to happen and no evidence for them.
And then even if they were to exist when
they did happen,
any such black holes would kind of
immediately,
um,
it'd be kind of completely unstable and
what,
it would just immediately decay into
something else.
So you wouldn't,
you're not going to produce a,
a dangerous black hole that way,
but,
but the first kind of,
I think what caused all this trouble is
that
people kind of wanted to,
to,
um,
to promote these extra dimensional
models even though there was no good
motivation for them.
And so they promoted them by saying,
well,
in principle,
you know,
since we don't know what happens at
higher energies,
the Lhc,
maybe evidence,
these extra mentions will show up,
but there's no good reason for that.
So,
but once people started promoting the
idea of these extra dimensions of my
job,
then people are like,
wow,
if they show up,
then maybe there'll be black holes.
And it was kind of a speculation on top
of speculation on how to speculation.
But it's all,
it's all suffered.
There's has been,
has no reason to believe that any such
thing could,
could,
could possibly be true.
The thing that most fascinates me about
this whole subject is,
is something that,
that,
that promise,
it quickly gets very technical.
But,
but there,
there's a,
there's some,
there's,
there's an area of mathematics which is
known as representation theory.
And from when,
when I thinking and it's thinking about
it is in terms of what are,
what physicists were often called
symmetries.
So,
so for instance,
one of the basic facts about the laws of
nature is that they're,
um,
they're,
they're symmetric.
Laws of nature are the same at,
you know,
if you move,
if you move in any direction,
are you moving time back and forth?
The Laws of physics don't change.
If you rotate things around in three
dimensions,
the laws of physics don't change.
And so,
so the,
the so called symmetries and um,
and these,
these,
these cemeteries have very important,
um,
physical implications.
So friends,
the fact that the laws of physics don't
change as if you change your,
if you move in time,
has physical implication that,
that there's this thing called energy
and energy is conserved.
And same thing that and the fact that
laws of physics don't change.
If you move back and forth in different
directions in space implies that there's
a,
um,
something called momentum and momentum
is conserved and doesn't change and as
you move,
as you evolve in time.
And so,
so these very,
very fundamental facts about physics are
kind of deeply grounded in the
symmetries of,
of nature.
And so to a mathematician,
this,
this question is,
um,
is a question about what we call about
groups and representations of these
groups.
So if you go into any math department
and look at what they're doing,
you'll see that you know that a lot,
a lot of people and different kinds of
mathematics are studying different
structures,
which are all so called groups.
And they're often when studying what are
called representations of these groups.
So even people setting num number theory
kind of abstract things about,
about prime numbers or something,
they're also studying groups and certain
representations,
these groups.
So there's kind of a,
to the extent that mathematics has a
kind of a unifying theme and a unifying
principle which shows up in different
areas of mathematics.
It's about this row,
this,
these representations and representation
theory.
And the thing that most strike when the
most of the things that most strikes me
out physics and was fascinating to me
about it is that if you look at quantum
mechanics,
quantum mechanics initially it looks
like a very odd structure.
It doesn't,
it's not something that we can,
we have any kind of intuitive
understanding of it doesn't look like,
um,
you know,
like what the way we're used to thinking
about physics based on everyday
experience.
But if you look at the mathematical
structure and the basic structures of
quantum mechanics,
they're exactly the structures that show
up in this theory,
in this theory of representations.
So there's a kind of a deep
relation between math and physics,
which is surrounding this whole notion
of symmetries and representations of
symmetries.
So,
so that's,
so that's one thing that's always
fascinated me and,
and my own research,
my own interest is,
is in kind of developing t taking a lot
that's been learned in mathematics.
There's a lot that's been learned in
mathematics over the years about how to
think about representations and how to
construct them and how to work with
them.
Some of it has made its way into physics
had been using in physics and,
and was using a physics since the early
days of quantum mechanics.
And,
um,
so for instance,
one of the great kind of to the extent
there is a,
uh,
a kind of hero of this book I wrote
about this.
It's a mathematician and called the
Herrmann vial who was a special,
who kind of was one of the first people
to understand how quantum mechanics work
and to understand the relation to
representations.
But,
but,
but I,
I,
anyway,
I think there,
there's still a lot to be learned and
that way and raised specifically the so
called standard model has this group of
symmetries which is called the gauge
symmetry and it's an influential group
and the standard kind of physics
conjecture or understanding of the
representations that this group is that
there is that that should not be an
interesting question.
There should only be a trivial
representation of this group.
But anyway,
my conjecture is that there's,
there's actually a much more interesting
question there.
And,
uh,
and pursuing that you can,
pursuing this question of how do you
deal with the,
with the gauge symmetry of this theory
and in terms of using ideas from
representation theory that are,
um,
that are more well known in mathematics
that haven't been used in physics
before,
that you can actually get somewhere.
So that's maybe a bit too technical,
but that's about as good as I can do
with this.
So it's hard to say and there's,
um,
we'll get improved.
I don't know.
There's a lot of the problem with,
with elegant is actually an interesting
a question.
Maybe just say what,
what is,
what does elegance and what does it,
what is beauty?
I guess so one,
the one thing,
one thing that's come up even within
this,
the string theory,
um,
issue is this question are,
you know,
is this a beautiful idea or a beautiful
theory?
So,
so my colleague Brian Greene as,
um,
irritant,
very,
very good book about this called the
elegant universe.
And so he's,
um,
and so,
and,
and within,
within,
within physics,
this is our,
I mean we're,
we're,
we're often raise struck by some of
these basic ideas are,
um,
what we would like to our race striking
and that we like to,
in a way which we like to describe as
being elegant are beautiful.
But,
um,
the problem with w with those,
that terminology,
especially with the terminology of
beauty is that beauty means a lot of
different things to a lot of different
people and a lot of different ways in
which things can be beautiful.
But this really has very specific
meaning and,
and which is more along the lines of
elegance,
which is that we say that an idea as
beautiful or elegant in mathematics or
physics,
if,
you know,
a very simple principle and raised
simple idea or a simple set of ideas,
it turns out to be very powerful and,
and you know,
leads to all sorts of unexpected
structure and unexpected predictions.
And,
um,
I think maybe the,
what I find is,
is,
is the most beautiful,
most elegant thing about this whole
subject is a little bit what I was
trying to explain earlier.
If for instance,
this idea,
maybe just to say this idea that the,
um,
the fact that the laws of physics are
the same as you as you move in time
means that has very unexpected and
significance.
It means that there,
there is this thing called energy and
um,
you can associate a number of cold
energy to us to institute a physical
systems and it's not going to change it
as,
as you,
as time evolves.
So the,
um,
I mean that,
that's actually the,
so,
so in,
in,
in classical physics,
that's actually,
they're there,
that's a theorem called an annoyed.
There's,
they're,
um,
after,
uh,
method one called [inaudible] there.
Uh,
so,
so there,
it's a little bit of a slight non
trivial theater,
Amanda,
and that,
that's certainly a,
a beautiful theorem.
What,
what fascinates me more is that in
quantum mechanics,
northern scenario isn't even a theorem.
It's just kind of,
it's just implicit in the definition.
Just the,
um,
the way you set things up,
it just is automatically true.
So it's a,
anyway,
they're there,
there's a theorem and,
and approve in classical physics and
then you,
you,
you start thinking about quantum
mechanics and you think about it and
then it's just kind of automatically
true.
There's not even a theorem anymore.
And it's like,
that's just beautiful.
Well,
I think,
I mean,
any kind of thing that human beings do
and there's certain politics to it and
certain economic politics and Polish
with field.
So,
but,
um,
mathematics is actually a relatively
healthy field these days.
I mean,
people are,
you know,
are,
are making,
making good progress and a lot of
different work,
different ways.
And it's also so,
so anyway,
I,
I've,
I've kind of lived part of my
professional life and mathematics and
part of the physics.
And,
um,
and one thing to say about that,
that mathematics is,
it's a,
I think a kid can have its problems,
but,
but it's,
it's actually hasn't seen
it.
It hasn't seen a lot of the problems of
other sciences and politically,
partly,
partly also the
wonderful thing about mathematics is
since so much of it is what people are
doing is completely useless.
Nobody,
I'm nobody kind of in the outside world
we're like cares very much.
You don't really have,
you don't have kind of a right and left
and people getting in,
you know,
kind of ideology coming in because there
isn't any,
it just doesn't actually connect up to
the kinds of things that people who were
worried about ideologically worry about.
So most of mathematics,
which it doesn't,
it doesn't tell you anything one way or
another about global warming or about,
you know,
health care or about any other number of
things you might care about.
So,
so it's a mathematics.
It is immune to a lot of exterior pot,
real world politics because of that and
the academic politics or it's there.
But,
um,
I,
I think it's actually less than a lot of
fields.
I,
one of my colleagues likes to say that
mathematics is the,
he thinks that about the only subject
that he knows of it in academia or in
the real world where if two people
disagree about something,
if it,
if people are studying some mathematical
object,
then there's what you're supposed to be
a proof and they disagree about whether
this proof works or not.
They will,
you know,
go into a room,
sit down and talk about it and fairly
quickly or at the end of the day one of
them will admit they're wrong.
And then he says,
you know,
that the problem a lot of companies,
this is,
this is just doesn't happen.
Whereas mathematics,
this is just happens all the time.
And so the people,
um,
there is this notion of logic and proof
and rigor,
which we can all allows us to kind of
all stay on one track.
Physics is,
um,
well the other thing I'd say that
physics,
first of all,
physics is a very complicated subject
with many,
many different things.
A string theory and particle physics or
only a small part of a physics.
So when I talk about physics and I
talked about them and the problems of
those subjects,
it's really a problem is of a very
small,
you know in one discipline,
in one subfield of physics and a lot of
physicists,
people are kind of happily going on and
doing their science and quite
successfully and it has nothing to do
with it and they get very,
very annoyed when I hear people going on
about the problems of string theory and
as if that's some big problem for
physics because it's not their problem.
String theory in particle physics
suffers.
I think a lot from the,
from this business of being from its own
success,
from not having any,
I'm not nobody kind of,
it kind of has it.
Has it been able to come up with any
really good ideas to make positive
progress just because there's been no
experimental evidence to give you a clue
as to which direction to go and that the
subject is,
I think traditionally been very
connected often in,
in at least from mathematicians point of
view and very faddish way that
everybody,
all the smart people in the subject.
The idea was it was,
it would all kind of jump at the same
problem and I'll try and work in the
same problem very often because the,
the subject was driven by experiment and
you know,
somebody would go out and turn on a new
accelerator like the LSD at higher
energy and this is certainly going to
happen next year if the LHC is see
something unexpected,
everyone in the whole field is going to
be trying to explain that one thing.
And so you have a very kind of,
a little bit of kind of faddish
sociology that everybody is trying to
do,
do the same thing at the same time.
Or as in other fields like mathematics,
people kind of spread out and develop
expert their expertise and work on
different things.
So part of the problem of the politics
of particle theory and has been that you
have people used to the idea that well
you should,
you know,
look around and see what these smart
people are working on and I should work
in the same thing as them.
And so you've got,
you have all these people kind of trying
to do this.
And so string theory then got identified
back in 84 as being the hot topic.
And for a lot of reasons,
partly,
um,
you know,
probably cause it was an intriguing
idea,
but,
but partly also because one of the,
uh,
there's one of the great geniuses of our
subject that Edward Whitton,
who's a
fantastic genius,
has done these amazing things and you
know,
he got very interested in it and he
started promoting the idea that this is
a very promising idea.
And so everyone kind of jumped,
jumped on it.
And,
uh,
and,
and my,
my initial reaction at that time,
that was,
I was just getting out of graduate
school at that time.
And you know,
my,
partly the way I work and the way I
think I,
I wasn't so interested.
The idea of trying to do it at the same
thing as everybody else,
I would prefer to work on something a
bit different.
And partly also,
it didn't seem to me that,
you know,
it wasn't that this was obviously a good
idea.
It might be a good idea.
I might not,
but,
but there were obvious problems with it
from the beginning.
And so anyways,
so starting in [inaudible] 84,
everybody started working on this and I
think my reaction to it was,
well,
you know,
that's great that they're doing this and
what's going to happen is what normally
happens in the subject is that after six
months or a year or two years,
people will see whether it's a good idea
or not and you know,
you,
and if it's not a good idea,
they'll,
they'll move on.
And the really peculiar thing that
happened here was that,
you know,
25 years later,
this is still,
um,
there's still a lot of people doing
this.
I mean,
it,
it really kind of caught fire and even
without succeeding it,
it's still kind of developed into this
hole,
into this huge subject.
And,
um,
it kind of in some sense kind of
achieves some kind of critical mass and
more and more people were working on it
and they're working on it for so long
that people ended up kind of devoting
their careers to it.
And it's a very,
very difficult and a very complicated
subject.
And,
uh,
it,
it requires quite a lot of time just to
even get to the point of understanding
what's going on.
So you had lots of want more and more
people working on this for investing
more and more of their time and their
careers and their lives and it,
and,
and I think it really got to the
unfortunate that people were kind of
unwilling to kind of admit that this
wasn't working.
And it's a natural human reaction to an
idea of your fond of that you put a lot
into it to,
it's kind of hard to get to,
to get you to admit often wellmade this
doesn't work.
And,
and,
and this was kind of happening very much
in spades in this story I think has been
very hard to get people to kind of admit
that this is something that hasn't
worked out.
There's actually kind of two that,
to kind of two things.
What does the blog else I wrote wrote
this book.
And so the,
um,
anyway,
for,
for many years I was,
I wasn't very happy with what was going
on there and I was kind of observing,
Kay,
this is becoming more and more
problematic.
There's this,
you know,
not only are our people kind of not
admitting that this isn't working out,
but you know,
there's this,
there's this whole that,
you know,
there's a lot of kind of public
promotion of the subject and,
uh,
and it's very difficult,
complicated ethnography.
A lot of people don't or don't
understand it.
And so it's,
this is really not a healthy situation
so that someone should kind of,
you know,
and kind of clearly explained to larger
community of physicists and,
and,
and also at the non physicists,
it,
you know exactly what the situation is
here.
And,
uh,
and so I,
I wrote an article about this and then I
finally wrote this book and it took,
it took,
it took a while to get the book
publishers.
That's a long and interesting story.
But,
but then while after,
I guess it's after,
after the book was written,
I also started a,
started to see,
there were a couple of other physicists
would started blogs.
And I thought,
well this is an interesting,
interesting thing to try to do.
And I can both talk about his issues
related to string theory and things,
which I was trying to get out through
the book but also kind of follow it and
on a day to day basis and also just kind
of write about whatever I'm interested
in.
So the um,
the blog,
I,
I guess I don't worry a lot about who
about the,
about the audience for it.
It's kind of written things.
I realize it's very much,
it's really just kind of whatever,
whatever I would like to read.
So I'm going to run,
I'm kind of writing whenever I would
like to read stuff to it.
So if there's somebody out there exactly
like me,
they much find is really fascinating and
if there's something quite different,
they find it not at all interesting.
And so,
but because of that it's um,
the kinds of things in the blog are
often,
you know,
if I,
if I learned something or something new,
interesting going on and even in pure
mathematics I'll be writing about that
or pretty much anything going on in
between mathematics and physics.
They're writing about that,
writing a lot about the LHC and um,
and also just about whatever is going on
in this controversy over string theory
and had done,
it's kind of,
it's interesting that more kind of keeps
happening without this,
my book came out and there was at the
same time there's a book by another
physicist,
um,
with a similar point of view to mind and
all came to that came out with that,
that causes a lot of controversies with
a lot of reviews and a lot of argument
going on in these blogs.
And a lot of people refer to this as the
string wars.
And so the,
there's this very,
for for a year or two there,
there was a kind of a right,
interesting.
If you're interested,
it's kind of thing.
There's an interesting warfare in terms
of blog postings.
And comments going on on my site and
grey as others.
And that was all sort of with,
that would lead to all sorts of strange
things.
Seven.
And I mean I,
it depends.
I often learn interesting things from
comment,
you know,
so,
so now that the blog is fairly well
known,
so people will write in comments and
I've logged off and telling me about
something I hadn't heard about her new
button you don't know about and that
that's very interesting order.
They'll,
they'll often send it to me privately by
email saying,
hey,
you might be interested in this.
And so I get a lot of that.
I learned a lot that way.
Um,
or what interesting thing I thought I'm
using about the whole string theory
thing discussion was that it say,
uh,
it really is,
it's an incredibly complex and difficult
subject.
And so it's really hard to over
emphasize how it's a subject that really
nobody understands very well.
And even the people who are the most
experts at it are.
And it's amazing experience of having a
conversation with some Nobel prize
winners who people are thought of as
the,
the brightest people in this field and
asking them what they think of the
string theory and they'll say,
no,
I don't know.
I don't really understand what's going
on.
I don't want to comment on it.
And it's just,
I'm baffled by it.
So one interesting thing about the,
some of these discussions and the blog
was I found one way to have to figure
out exactly what's going on in,
in string theory and whether,
you know,
if something is really a problem or or
not is to just put up my understanding
of it,
you know,
in a blog posting or in a comment or
whatever.
And then fairly quickly you would find
that either,
you know,
either I was wrong and there,
there was some reason that this actually
made sense even though I thought it
didn't and this would,
I would,
I would quickly,
often abusive Leebee explained to me
what an idiot I was and why this was,
you know,
here's the,
here's the answer,
what you really should have known or,
and then then I found out that,
okay,
I learned something.
Or,
or,
or often I would found out that if I was
writing,
if there really was a problem here,
the answer I would get would often be
just this abuse of,
Oh,
you know,
you're a complete jerk and you're a
moron and,
but,
but no,
no,
no scientific answer to,
to the,
to the scientific question.
So,
uh,
that was one that was actually an
interesting way to kind of see exactly
what the state of research and the
subject was by kind of probing it and
trying to an egg and getting that kind
of response from some of the more
hostile people in the subject.
Okay.
I mean,
I,
it's mostly a positive thing.
I mean,
one thing to say about the w,
one of the main problems with,
with the blogs,
one of the most annoying thing about the
logs is,
especially if,
if,
if a,
if a lot of people are reading it,
you're really in a situation where
there's a small number of people who
really understand this and know what's
going on and have something really
sensible to say about it.
There's a very large number of people
who have some kind of interest in it and
you know,
have the time and energy to sit there
and write uninformed things on your blog
and,
and kind of just so,
so I actually did,
I think I'd like some logs actually
delete a lot of the comments submitted
to my blog and try to keep the noise
level down.
And,
um,
so,
so that's the most,
probably the most discouraging thing
about the whole experience is just as
the number of people out there who kind
of want to go on about this and argue
about this but don't know what they're
talking about and want to kind of fill
the internet and all information sources
they get their hands on with kind of
uninformed nonsense.
So there's a lot of that,
but the,
um,
but,
but just the kind of discussion of the
other subject and have its problems,
which I think went on in these blogs and
which are in which,
you know,
if you're interested,
you can now have an going to go and see
and read.
I don't think there's really any other
form of,
you know,
it's an amazing format for that.
There's really no other way that,
you know,
that discussion could,
it could be held in that way.
And um,
and,
and also,
I mean the Internet just provides us
amazing access to the information of a
sort,
which is just totally unlike anything
we've had before.
You can just google some term and
immediately have access to all sorts of
uh,
often high level discussions of the
subject.
And um,
I think the one,
well it's actually made some of the um,
faddishness of particle theory actually
a bit worse in the sense that one thing
that used to kind of slow down and fads
was just the,
how long it took to communicate them to
people.
I mean,
you know,
the certain prominent people might have
started working on some idea at
Princeton or Harvard,
but it would take a while for that news
of that and understanding of what these
people were doing to filter out to the
rest of the community.
And if people want it to kind of jump on
it and pursue it in a faddish way,
it would take them while to even find
out about it.
Whereas now everybody's kind of,
every night there's a new set of
preprints coming out in the pre print
server and people logging in and looking
at these.
And the minute that somebody has some
new thing,
which is becoming a kind of faddish
thing to work on,
everybody throughout the world has it at
exactly the same time when their desktop
and can start thinking about it and
working on it.
And so it kind of makes that even more
so than it used to be.
[inaudible].